my clue is remember I gave you I gave
you that that pair of equations before
and I said hey what do you think might
be the best way to combine these and
when you looked at it you said oh I
think we can eliminate something right
now elimination happens to be only
really useful in a very small number of
cases right we're like oh the number of
X's is exactly the same well the number
of wires is exactly the same it actually
doesn't happen very frequently for that
reason it's actually the other primary
method that gets used 99% of the time
it's not solved by elimination it's
solved by substitution so one of these
equations I'm going to substitute in to
the other which do you think is easier I
think the first interview the second so
my first line will be substitute 1 into
2 that's my first line there's my clue
now maybe you got to here in your life I
don't know what that looks like in this
context and that's why we're meeting it
now rather than back in simultaneous
equations let me show you how I would do
the working yes rule is Shh all right
because I'm substituting wide one
equation went into equation 2 what that
means is everywhere I saw a y in
equation 2 I'm not gonna write Y I'm
gonna write X plus 2 because Y and X
plus 2 are supposed to be
interchangeable
that's what that means okay so therefore
my first line of working will look like
this there's an x squared and then
instead of writing y squared I'm going
to write X plus 2 that's the whole
object X plus 2 squared okay so it's a
little bit weird that I have to put in
this weird complicated object in there
but I have to put the whole thing and
square the whole thing cuz look all of Y
is being squared so I guess that means
everything on the right-hand side also
has to be square that is equal to 4 so
you can see another one of the reasons
why we're doing this skill now rather
than earlier is because all of a sudden
you've got to bring together all these
skills that like we've used in isolated
ways and now all of a sudden you just
have to know oh I know what to do with
this
I better expand okay
so that is a whole other coefficient on
its own what is this when I expand the
brackets so the most common error here
because people are thinking of a whole
lot of other stuff there's just lots of
your brain is to say well that squared
is x squared and that square is 4 and
not remembering that actually there's
this extra guy in the middle okay so
have a look at you're working once
you've got that though everything does
work out you subtract 4 from both sides
so they're gone okay you can collect
some like terms how many X Squared's do
you have two of them you've got that 4x
still hanging around this some common
factors here you could divide through by
right namely ah now I know you divide
through by the number two that leaves me
with this I'm deliberately not going to
divide through by X even though it's
common here's why let's just go ahead
and solve this and see what happens if I
factorize I get this and this has
solutions what are the solutions
count'em one solution two solutions now
let's just rewind for a second and
suppose I didn't do it this way
suppose back here or here if I've
divided through by X what would happen
well if you divide everything in this
line by X you get an X plus 2 what
happens in the right hand side it's just
the just 0 right 0 divided by X is 0 now
this is not wrong in fact you can see
I've used that over here I won X plus 2
equals 0 but there's something missing
right do you see like by dividing
through by X the solution I would have
got from here has just vanished it's
disappeared this guy only has one
solution but I'm supposed to have two
okay so this is why maybe it's worth
writing with an extra color over on the
left hand side don't divide through
don't divide by variables you notice
when I divide it by the number 2 there
was no problem I still ended up with
all the solutions but if you divide by
variables you eliminate solutions is the
way that we would say it okay all right
so you got some X values does anyone
already gone and find the Y values yep
let me just drop them down what was the
first one value you got when x is 0 Y is
going to be 2 and by the same logic when
X is negative 2 y is 0 yes
okay so what does this mean well let's
have a look you don't have to do this
next bit but I'm going to encourage you
especially if you're like I feel like I
get this
I'd like to progress to the next thing
it's just such a valuable tool for you
you told me this is a straight line and
you told me this is a circle both of
which you know how to draw okay you know
have to draw them if this takes you a
long time then then skip it you can do
it all just by algebra but if you can't
even just draw a rough one just like we
do over there you can confirm very
quickly
there's y equals x plus 2 that these are
indeed the solutions 0 2 where is that 0
2 it's up the top that's that point
right there right you see it 0 because
it's not moved from the x axis Y axis
sorry and to it it's up and what about
this guy was that it's the left hand 1
negative 2 0 okay so graphing is a
wonderful tool just like the sense check
you used in a trigonometry questions
earlier it's a great tool to say yeah
that looks right cool I'm in the right
ballpark right if you've got negative
values of x over here you know that that
doesn't make sense
ok